[Music]  looks like Sharna Burgess and Bonner  Bolton have taken their ballroom  chemistry to the bar  the Dancing with the Stars pair were  spotted enjoying what looks like a  flirty night out at the cowboy Palace  saloon in Chatsworth California on  Tuesday the redheaded Beauty and  handsome cowboy were all smiles on the  dance floor Bolton even had his arms  wrapped around his pro partner as she  grabbed onto his hand in a sweet moment  captured by cameras whether we've got a  real showmance on our hands is hard to  say for now but there's no denying teen  denim and diamonds chemistry both on and  off the floor  thanks to this bison and boy did they  after Monday night's hand gate moment  that had everyone buzzin well I haven't  actually ever blushed on this show when  this I think I blushed several times  tonight  um and still blushing sir so there's a  first for everything  [Music]  you